done and I need every bit of my seven
after eight hours of dueling I need to
man I took ambien ton playing out there
so I've slept straight ten hours woke up
had like four hours left was great the
way there I had chin take when he's on
how about chin that we were [ __ ]
smuggling cocaine or some somewhat here
just take these so you sleep the pill is
tidy it on it's a quarter of a tic-tac
yeah there's a [ __ ] fragment yep
you're Chinese like we're in line is I
click around like a mine asking to
smuggle drugs in yes why are you looking
around like this he's all I don't know
man once they check out what if they
check the speck in your pocket then you
deserve to get caught he's like nah any
of hey why would you take your Negus I'm
just nervous man I got there no hang
with it you [ __ ] buck a lot and you
for not only a drug mule I was gonna
have side yeah you should have seen him
sweating I'm like what are you doing Rin
I didn't give you some [ __ ] coke team
a Muslim your Brum per about how about
they didn't work for me I took full a
big boy I took how are you I take your
picture man handed boy and there's like
two or three on there uh-huh
took those two I'm sitting there
watching TV I'm like I am wide awake
that's lady I'm like a can I get a
couple beers down bears like I mean more
crunk and I feel like dancing and then I
took two more didn't work ah drew around
my mouth like to know exactly when you
big boy you big boy it takes a lot in my
buddy went to Mexico my buddy went to
Mexico I got a couple friends were
what's the word they like to chase
certain sensations so they bring a lot
of cash down in Mexico talks you know it
speaks and well he's got a bunch of cash
packed in his bag and all of a sudden
he's walking through big old German
Shepherds [ __ ] jumped on him he said
what the [ __ ] dogs dog is literally
trained to sniff cash in the bag sir guy
goes like this looks at him sees the
cash and reaches in he just reaches in
and grabs that he pulls out and goes God
just took it from him yeah
listen Mexico yep dogs dogs train sniff
cash and how about that how about gin we
go through Australian Customs and all
this [ __ ] and these dealing customs
doing it stop for Qing it's not too
narrow
two hours oh come on why I did did you
no idea maybe it has sleep until I maybe
what do you mean well two hours two
different lines so I had to go through
you know when we like an immigration
thanks for the random [ __ ] I don't
know so wing up why your passport drew
and then you scan your face yeah for
where reason I'm sure they let you go
through Brenda bright away
maybe next my ex dying so I went to
another wait they scan your face what is
this this is new spring right though
just go scan your face go don't fill out
a crown I don't know if I want the
government knowing what my face is when
they call they call lobsters bugs out
there yeah they do well they're in the
better resident better they are shut the
[ __ ] up about animals I'm just talking
about out strafing well and he would say
oh happy to go there yeah they why do we
call them bugs cuz they yeah I'm tell
you this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch it Tom oh dude what's going to
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing [ __ ] it
did you sit [ __ ] you [ __ ] dark wood
I'll shut up Brian will you finally to
give a [ __ ] well well kind of
wheelbarrow say what I said to [ __ ]
Chris D'Elia
hello serious Mia who's that listen if
you feeling froggy we go ahead and leap
all right now you look at the trouble
and you be in disrespect filming well
there's all the head trouble here okay
stop here you see I do so I do these
live shows I just got back from
Australia and it's comedy mix it with
fight breakdown and I just ran questions
and at every fan question I can without
the benefit of everyone always asked me
why how can we get a fight fighters
union going how do you see the fire
association going and I say man it's
like wrangling cats
everyone's out to get theirs because
it's not you know it's not like other
sports like your your manager your your
publicist your the talent and you're all
wrapped in one
so when you're that guy it's tough to
get people to come together as a group
so I don't this something wrong touch on
um do that that is such a dish that was
his whole entire 30 minute interview
plus like a there's so much to cover and
talk about when it comes down to the
Union doing each one actually work are
we ready for it
I think emotionally I think we're
waiting for but mentally and
structurally no no glue yet now agree
went out there in leather helmets right
now so it's football yeah for real and
it's not man but and what the US you did
a right date but per their business plan
they didn't pay us enough and we're all
starving
we all need money so we can't get battle
fights good that's what happened
that's right one Tom MacGregor let's
just go viscometer four years ago cast a
welfare check like singing
hundred-dollar years ago four years ago
you know he's gonna make 100 million
dollars all over don't worry the hard
bass or 200 hundred those [ __ ]
are rough yeah this is what's so
interesting about if I think more than
the fire itself the build-up is going to
be the best thing ever the best they're
not this hard hardest [ __ ] irish crew
going up against all know it's just like
the only great why did you buy issue
when the mainstream media goes it's a
ship fire jian hood with hold on in what
we're going to break it down but you got
freakin andre ward versus Kovalev to
this weekend's taught the two light
heavyweights ranked top five in the
world overall pound per pound yeah no
one's talking about it because what
America and what the world cares about
is entertainment that's why this fight
is so big no it's getting good wing
everyone wants to know what's going on
here
no one can screwed it's not a circus act
it's nothing like that
there's a there is a chance there is a
chance you got MIT this Tony that a
Conor McGregor in some weird fashion
lands some is that left hand that has
starched some of the very best in the
world to mix martial arts if that lands
for him in weather could he's gonna get
not mean I hope with those lawmen I hope
he does not remote 100% not happening
but
it is at the end of boxing nah no no no
think so no no because then I think
didn't a widow be like well the
arguments will be always shot it was too
old well whatever initially there's no
money on pretty much air so you know I'm
friends with tons of boxes don't follow
them on social media
one thing I'm surprised at is how many
boxes are hidden on this fight